foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday March 15th
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
filters on social media are getting more
and more advanced now rather than adding
just rabbit ears or a giant tongue some
can knock decades off your appearance
and two of these effects released by
Tick Tock last month use image altering
technology with Hyper realistic results
they're called bold glamor and teenage
look not everyone on the app though is
okay with the results you guys this this
is the problem look
you can't even
you can't even tell it's a filter
anymore this filter is terrifying like
dystopian level terrifying over 25
million Tick Tock videos have been made
using these two effects as of Tuesday
sparking fresh debate about the impact
of such image altering technology on the
people exposed to it wsj reporter Sarah
Ashley O'Brien has been looking into
these effects and the backlash and she
joins us now hi Sarah thanks for coming
on the show thanks for having me can you
start by describing these new effects
what do they look like sure so you open
up the tick tock app in the camera
function and you'll see something at the
bottom left of your screen that says
effects right so one of the new effects
that people are applying is called bold
glamor when you turn it on it'll turn
your face into kind of a sculpted
cheekbone plumped lips groomed eyebrow
poreless skin version of yourself so
there's another one called teenage look
that people have been using
um that kind of shows a de-aged version
of you you so maybe shaving off 20 years
of you know back to when you were a
teenager depending on sort of how old
you currently are there's also some that
will simply you know apply freckles to
your face and some that apply
exaggerated eyelashes different sort of
enhanced Beauty effects Sarah have you
tried any of these filters on yourself I
have yeah for research purposes of
course and I was pretty surprised I kind
of looked like I could be related to a
Kardashian when I tried the bull glamor
effect how do these effects work because
they're not filters that some listeners
might be familiar with right right so
effect versus filter is sort of where
they're found in the app now Tick Tock
isn't really divulging much about how
these effects work but there's been some
speculation that they are using
something called generative adversarial
networks which essentially looks at what
they can currently see through your
camera so what your face currently looks
like and then it's mapping that against
a data set of other images and creating
a new face sort of based on your or
current phase and based off of this
database of images and what sort of
really surprising people what people are
talking about with this is just like how
realistic it is in sort of the past with
filters and effects it's that you could
see where their technology came into
play you would put your hand in front of
the filter and the filter would flub or
distort but this is like you know you
can try to touch your face and your face
is being touched by your hands and it's
staying sort of the same with the effect
what are users who've tried out these
features saying about them yeah so
there's been a lot of people that are
saying that this is something that could
potentially be really problematic for
people's self-esteem so has there been a
backlash then to these effects if people
feel that way yeah there's definitely
been a push for people saying you know
this should be banned they're worried
about people that are teenagers that are
trying this out and maybe don't know the
effect that it could have on their
mental health I spoke with Jennifer
Mills a psychology professor at York
University in Toronto she basically said
that bull glamor could ultimately have a
contrast effect on people which is that
when they look at themselves after they
saw this filtered effect driven version
of themselves it might make them
actually feel worse about themselves
because they're seeing sort of an ideal
version of themselves not just like a
model or a celebrity but an ideal
version of themselves compared with
their actual self and the effect might
be that has like a negative impact on
their their sense of well-being their
mental health what is Tick tock's
response been to all of this Tick Tock
hasn't directly commented on some of the
claims about what it could do to
people's mental health but they just
sort of said that they celebrate
people's being true to themselves and
filters and effects should be fun and
that they're part of having fun on Tick
Tock so Tick Tock created these effects
is it possible that users could create
kind of their own effects their own AR
tools that lead to kind of the same
results Tick Tock has made it possible
for anyone to create effects for tick
tock so they on something called effect
house a year ago and that sort of opened
up the capability for anybody to create
an effect and have it be available on
The Tick Tock platform that said the
Bold glamor the teenage look these two
effects that are really realistic and
that people have been marveling over
they are ones that Tick Tock itself
created so it's unclear sort of how
advanced tick tock's technology was
versus what the tools are that they make
available to people this isn't the first
time we've heard a backlash to the use
of filters or effects or you know even
Photoshop in movies and magazines why
should we consider you know this to be
any different yes there's been backlash
against Photoshop editing for decades
now but one of the things that's really
different about this is it doesn't
require anything from the user right so
you just simply open your camera on The
Tick Tock app and it will map your face
and put this new filter over your face
and that sort of lack of anything from
the user is what differs from Photoshop
or face tune and some of these other
apps which require somebody to go in and
do some of the tweaking on their end to
say like I want whiter teeth or I want
to Chisel my cheeks a bit and you're
sort of putting in more effort rather
than simply just like opening up and
suddenly appearing drastically different
yes sir tell me a little bit more about
that because you've covered this for a
long time do we expect to see these
kinds of effects these types of
applications move maybe away from just
social media to other areas of tech
where people might be using this to
change their image yeah I mean I think
if I've learned anything covering tech
for many years it's that you can sort of
never underestimate people's ability to
sort of use technology in a way that it
wasn't necessarily intended to be used I
would not be surprised if people were to
take bold glamor effect and screen
record it and post it on their hinge or
dating profile there's maybe desire or
people that want to sort of use these
types of things on like Zoom or other
ways in which they're showing up
virtually in the world alright that's a
reporter Sarah Ashley O'Brien thanks for
joining us Sarah thanks so much and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
but a quick reminder before we close the
show we want to hear your questions
about generative artificial intelligence
do you have questions about the new gpt4
lenza or Google's Bard interested in how
these AI programs work or what they're
capable of email us a voice recording
with your AI question to tnb at wsj.com
or leave us a voicemail on
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
I'm Zoe Thomas from The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]